this video is brought to you by the
ridge wallet
[Music]
hey wisecrack greg here we're making a
short list of really funny things
chronic despair and unrelenting anxiety
probably don't make the cut
so why are so many comedians these days
talking about their mental health and
more importantly
why is it so freaking funny i knew that
i was gaining weight because my belt
stopped fitting around my neck the same
way that it used to
indeed over the last few years and
especially since robin williams tragic
death in 2014
we've seen more and more comments make
material out of their struggles with
depression
anxiety and other mental health issues
pete davidson for example
has made a running gag of his mental
health issues on saturday night live
oh no no no i was born depressed but it
might make me feel better
if i was on tv more and aparna nancharla
has done the same thing with her anxiety
and like if you don't have anxiety the
way i would describe it
is like there's an edgy improv group in
your brain
and john mullaney has been cracking
jokes about his own mental health
struggles and addiction issues
since early on in his career i actually
just quit drinking a couple
months ago because uh oh i'm not exactly
slap happy about it myself
meanwhile comics like bill hader and bo
burnham have been open about their
experiences
with performance anxiety to come to
terms with your anxiety
on the road you mean in front of
thousands of people a night
very very abstract now stand-up comedy
might not seem like the most
obvious medium for exploring mental
health struggles given that for most of
its history
it's peddled largely in quips punchlines
and gags purely for laughter's sake
i wish they made fajita cologne because
that stuff smells good
but this recent shift raises some
interesting questions
for one thing how do we get from bob
hope style one-liners
i went to the dentist this morning only
had a dollar what happened had to get
buck teeth
to comedians dissecting the most
intimate details
of their mental health struggles if i'd
had a gun right here
i would have just brought it up one
smooth movement
just like going oh they have french
crushed pizza
and is this change a good thing are
jokes about anxiety depression and other
mental health issues
just a new way to get a quick laugh out
of a tough situation
or is there something much deeper going
on let's find out in this wisecrack
edition on comedy
and mental health now before we dive
into a very serious discussion of some
extremely funny people
i want to give a quick shout out to the
people who help us keep the cameras
rolling
our sponsor for this week the ridge
wallet the holidays are coming up so
it's the perfect time to start thinking
about what you're going to get your
friends
and family especially the ones that are
hard to buy for
people never think about upgrading their
wallet but they would love it if you got
them one of these
the ridge wallet it's light sleek and
industrial
it holds up to 12 cards and has room for
cash
you can shop all 30 colors and styles to
find the perfect match for your loved
ones
each wallet is made with durable
material and comes with a lifetime
warranty
so your gift will last a lifetime with
over forty thousand five star reviews
you can't go wrong so don't wait for the
holidays to fly by
visit ridge.com wisecrack to view their
holiday guide
and when you're at checkout use promo
code wisecrack
for 10 off now back to the show while
it's no longer particularly shocking to
hear a comedian joke about depression
it's worth remembering that the recent
focus on mental health and stand-up
is pretty unprecedented for most of this
history stand-up comedy was less about
sharing funny confessional stories our
observations on stage
and more about crafting and delivering
clever setups and punchlines
my friend george is a radio announcer
and when he walks under a bridge you
can't hear him talk
in other words comics in the early to
mid 20th century
largely focus on laughter for its own
sake
and didn't necessarily ground their
material in their real life experiences
comics like bob hope along with jack
benny and milton berle built their sets
around rapid fire jokes
while their setups often made references
to their personal lives
this was only incidental the real goal
wasn't burying their soul on stage
it was landing a surprising punchline
and when i arrived at the airport lbj
gave me a wonderful reception a 21-gun
salute
and i've got the powder burns to prove
it the comedy of this era tended to be
escapists
more about taking a break from life's
hardships than engaging them head-on key
to that comedic escape is something
called
incongruity that is deliberately
creating a gap between what the audience
is expecting to hear
and what actually comes out of the
comedian's mouth philosophers as
disparate as kant
schopenhauer and kierkegaard have
theorized that incongruity is the main
ingredient
in generating laughter we laugh when
something disrupts our usual mental
patterns
and subverts our expectations the
classic example is the person who slips
on a banana pill
while walking the expectation here is
the person can walk
we are very used to seeing this we are
not used to seeing a person eat
instead thus the incongruity of course
this bit has become so cliche that is
practically an expectation in its own
right
which opens up the floor for new banana
pill related gags
[Music]
in pursuit of incongruity some comedians
got downright weird with their sets
creating completely nonsensical material
in an attempt to buck the audience's
expectations
stand-up comedians like charlie kallus
for instance
made a decades-long career out of
interrupting his own stories
with bizarre nonsensical noises and
facial expressions
even more abstractly 80s prop comic
gallagher built entire sets around
smashing watermelons
with the hammer and pulling large things
out of a giant couch
crap here's a potato chip
[Applause]
hey it was a different time audiences
attending these kinds of shows probably
weren't expecting a lot in the way of
substance
but even before gallagher's watermelon
smashing comedy was evolving to do more
than just dish out jokes
beginning in the 1950s and 60s a
so-called new wave of stand-up comics
like lenny bruce and george carlin begin
to push the boundaries of what could be
said on stage
by incorporating crude humor and social
satire into their sets
carlin for instance was famously
arrested on obscenity charges
following a televised routine about the
dirty words one wasn't supposed to say
on tv
[Music]
in a similar vein comics like sam
kennison used their stage time to attack
social norms and institutions generally
considered sacred
well michael if you ever think about
getting married you ever think you've
met the right woman you want to settle
down
change your life you do me a favor mike
remember this face
more so than earlier comedians these
comics acted as cultural critics
pointing out perceived hypocrisy
throughout history this has been a major
function of comedy and laughter
as scholarly mints writes the stand-up
comic acts as our comic spokesperson a
mediator
and articulator of our culture and our
contemporary anthropologists
more broadly mints contends that in
certain contexts the stand-up comic is
granted permission to express
feelings that would be difficult to
share outside the comedy club
you are satan's spawn filling the world
with
violent garbage you are in your nose
kill yourself it's the only way to save
your
soul while performing a skill comic can
enact an audience's frustrations with
the very real difficulties of
relationships
politics and so on in this way they can
provide
insights into our shared human
shortcomings insights that would be
entirely unacceptable to share
at the company picnic still for the most
part new wave comics tended to direct
their criticism outward at the broader
society
rather than attempting introspection and
that's what's so interesting about the
present moment which we will playfully
dove the new
new age of comedy more so than ever
before comics are turning a carl and
that's critical eye inward to comment on
themselves and their community
yeah i think i think it's hard for black
men especially to talk about depression
because we have so many cool words
available to us to undermine how we
really
feel you know as a result they're able
to broach hard truths that for years
have been off the table
even for the boldness of comics and
trust me when i say this
nothing is scarier than having to fight
your own mind
but is this necessarily a good thing
that brings us to one of the central
conflicts in this new
new age namely is laughter a the best
medicine
hey we're uh you know everything you do
is gonna end in annihilation and uh
entropy so what's the point i'm like
you're right you win again depression or
b
an unhealthy coping mechanism depressed
looking for any excuse to not get help
and the fact that some of my heroes were
messed up was a justification for that
that clips from laughing matters
a recent documentary about comedy and
mental health in it
famous actors and comics including sarah
silverman
wayne brady and rayne wilson speak
candidly about the mental health issues
they've dealt with
and explore the role that comedy has
played in their struggles
the documentary explores the potential
harm of using comedy to escape one's
mental health problems
i think performing can be a temporary
high but like all temporary highs
it doesn't last and you can chase that
high
night after night after night but
eventually there's gonna be a club
that's not open
or you're gonna have a night off and
you're gonna have to deal with
what happens in the silence like any
other addiction
the high of a great performance can
temporarily mask the pain
of depression anxiety and so on but it
does so without actually helping to
solve the underlying issues
and in some cases it can make them worse
and if you are thinking about
doing comedy as a substitute for therapy
it doesn't it doesn't work i tried i
tried for a long time
it doesn't work to put it bluntly the
documentary suggests that comedy and
laughter have been unproductive
and even destructive for many comedians
a way to tune out from a life that's
falling apart if that's true
is it fixable and specifically is there
a more constructive way to make people
laugh one that's less about avoiding
painful truths
and more about facing them to find out
we can turn to a guy who's not exactly
known for its
punchy one-liners philosopher and horse
enthusiast
frederick nietzsche in general nietzsche
had pretty serious beef with laughter
because he viewed it as a potential
threat to our quest for
self-actualization
as scholar mark weeds notes nietzsche
thought the most important human pursuit
was embracing our future our desires and
our power in the face of life's
absurdities
for him laughter undercuts this pursuit
indeed according to week's
interpretation of nietzsche
laughter with its ability to ground us
in the present moment
by overwhelming us with giggle fits and
good feelings
can distract from the all-important
philosophical quests
constantly striving to improve ourselves
in order to build a better future
to put it another way laughter has a
tendency to lift us momentarily out of
time
by cutting tension and poking holes in
the stories
we construct for ourselves laughter in
other words is a loss of the creative
tension
that the nichian hero needs to construct
a meaningful narrative of their life
a waste of a vital resource while
nietzsche is hardly an expert in laws
and stand-up comedy as we know it
totally didn't exist in 19th century
germany
he does have a point worth considering
as we've seen a lot of successful comedy
works by creating incongruity
pointing out gaps between expectation
and reality
in other words undercutting various
narratives we tell
ourselves about the way things ought to
go charlie kalas does this by literally
cutting himself off
while he tells a brief story and sam
kinnison does this by poking holes in
the societal narrative of a happy loving
marriage
in various ways comedians have
historically generated a lot of laughter
by disrupting the flow of personal and
societal narratives going by nietzsche
we might consider this a bad thing
because while comedians are
deconstructing old
and useless narratives they're not
necessarily offering new more productive
ones to take their place
and to bring it back to mental health in
nietzschean terms
comedy has failed some pretty funny
people by offering them a way to
temporarily undercut the narrative of
their own lives
in the process they can numb out and
avoid facing their own existential dread
and the mental health issues that might
come with it a lot of existing stand-up
comedy in other words
confirms nietzsche's worst fears about
laughter's potentially harmful effects
on the human spirit well excuse
me we can't help but wonder if nietzsche
might have been more okay with laughter
if he spent his time joking with his
friends instead of crying alone in the
woods
which hey hey hey you do you frederick
nevertheless
this criticism raises a question should
comics try to use laughter to confront
their problems
rather than to escape from them and what
might such a new approach be
while we have no evidence that any of
the comedians interviewed and laughing
matters dig nietzsche
they do outline what a more constructive
approach to comedy might look like
specifically an approach that transforms
their struggles
into something of a greater value rather
than just fodder for laughter
we all have these kind of things that
happen to us and
we can get through them you know we can
get through it and
and transform it and uh and use it
trauma and tragedy according to these
comics are not merely things to laugh at
even if it feels good rather they are
the raw materials that comedians can use
to craft entirely new narratives instead
of merely shredding apart outdated ones
you know if you're an artist who has a
chance to say something that might
actually connect with people or help
people
you don't take that chance
what good are you this approach to
comedy is distinctly nietzsche
mark wheats contends that in his later
work the philosopher made a kind of
uneasy peace with laughter
by challenging his readers to will a new
kind of laughter
one which leaves us both amused and
philosophically elevated
to put it another way nietzsche believed
that a constructive self-affirming
laughter was
possible but had yet to be realized in
his own time
he challenged his readers to invent a
new form of laughter that would support
heroic striving in the face of adversity
rather than denigrating such efforts as
being pointless and silly
and we'd argue that the stand-up comic
who uses their struggles with mental
health as material
is helping to make that new laughter a
reality when a comic crafts a good story
about their struggles
they aren't just entertaining they're
also creating a heroic narrative
that shows them facing off against the
real challenges
of being human and in the case of mental
health that means the difficulty of
being completely reliant
on a blob of electrified goo that
frequently malfunctions
in other words they're responding to
nietzsche's challenge
by generating laughter that brings
audiences and themselves
into direct contact with the past and
the future
rather than merely escaping into the
hilarity of the present
we can see this in the work of sarah
silverman like the other comedians
interviewed in laughing matters
she cites her difficult childhood as a
sort of origin story
for a comedy career in this way she
takes a direct look at her past
rather than running from it a hundred
percent of comedians
become comedians because somewhere in
their childhood
they needed to be funny in order to
survive
her refusal to use laughter as a way of
covering up past traumas
pops up again when silverman describes
what happened to the doctor
who prescribed her xanax as a teenager
the
psychiatrist who originally put me on it
hung himself
i mean i can't just skate by that it's
crazy notice how silverman laughs and
smiles while telling the story
but refuses to dismiss her psychiatrist
suicide
as something inconsequential she can
acknowledge the irony in the situation
and even chuckle at it without denying
the traumatic effect that these events
had on her younger self
what's more she explains precisely what
that effect was
drawing a narrative arc from her past
through her present
and into the future these years of
torture and shame
kind of became my superpower silverman
is literally framing her comedy career
in terms of a superhero's origin story
far from avoiding her problems
silverman embraces them as a key part of
a creative process
without romanticizing them as the sole
source of her funniness
depression doesn't make a joke out of
silverman silverman makes jokes out of
depression
she demonstrates that comedians can
transform mental health struggles
from a taboo subject into something
worth talking about
even celebrating if only for the
duration of a set
a partner and charla for a part applies
a similar technique to the topic of
anxiety
i feel like it's weirder to not have
anxiety than to have it because i feel
like if you're not scared
you're not paying attention you know
like i feel like if you open a newspaper
today skim
maybe three headlines you're just like
seems cool he's like what
everything's on fire even the newspaper
is on fire like what are you so chill
about
here nanchala frames anxiety not as a
failing
but as the only rational response to a
society that insists we post
happy photos of ourselves on instagram
while the world crumbles around us
that's not to say that everyone needs to
get stoked on their own depression or
anxiety but it's one way to deal
comics can also transform trauma into
connection with other comics or audience
members or
insomniacs watching grainy videos on
youtube
it's one of the reasons that i love
being a comedian
because if i can find comedy people
anywhere i go in the world and i have
i know i'm going to hear good stories
and i'm going to be sitting around with
people who are
also if not okay with being up
at least perhaps more honest about it
than other folks might be
and what's more nietzschean and
transforming trauma into purpose
by using their darkest moments to
generate laughter these comics aren't
just constructing their own heroic
narratives
they're offering us the chance to create
ours too in other words
if this guy can use humor to overcome
his mental health struggles
then maybe there's hope for us and our
friends and our cranky co-workers
the real mission is if your kid is sick
or your cousin is suffering or the guy
on the other side of the cubicle wall
shows up and you never know which person
you're gonna get
how can i make those people understand
that that person's not being a [ __ ]
that day
and that person is not being
melodramatic and it's not because
they're going through a phase
it's because they're sick by making
comedy intended to keep us alive and
striving for something greater these
comedians are generating the kind of
laughter which nietzsche might be damn
proud of
a laughter that serves to construct
rather than to tear down
and that's nothing to laugh at nah just
kidding that's pretty funny
i don't want to be out in the wasteland
fat and depressed like that
there's not going to be any prozac after
the collapse but what do you guys think
can comedy help us all become better
people or should comedians just stick to
smashing watermelons
shout out to gallagher let us know in
the comments and since we're on the
subject
if you or anyone you know was going
through a hard time yo please reach out
and ask for help
mostly because you deserve it inherently
but also because
y'all mean a lot to us and if you ever
need it you can find the link and phone
number for the national suicide
prevention lifeline
right here in the description below big
thanks to our patrons for all your
support
but be sure to subscribe and ring that
bell and as always thanks for watching
man
[Music]
peace
[Music]
you